welcome back you're watching in King
Live Standard Life in Aberdeen Asset
Management's have given more details of
their planned eleven billion pound
merger the two fund managers confirmed
they'd agreed a preliminary deal on
Saturday after the news was broken by
Sky News it's mark Kleiman both sets of
investors welcomed the news today with
standard life shares rising by more than
five and a half percent while Aberdeen
shares clomp by more than four percent
under the terms of the deal the two
current chief executives will become
co-chief executive while standard lives
chairman Sir Jerry Grimstone will be
chairman of the combined company and
he's with me now
so you're costing this very much us an
expansive merger a big aggressive move a
lot of people would say it's quite
defensive given the client's outflows
that you've both experienced lately I
did say that way we're creating a new
global champion no we're creating the
UK's largest active fund manager the
second largest in Europe 19th largest in
the world it's not often in the UK
nowadays you get a chance in financial
services and know to do things like that
we've been thinking about this for a
long period of time it's been something
that's been in the making for a long
time in these people businesses you can
only do these deals if the people want
to do it so very important ingredient
was bringing the two CEOs into alignment
and looking at their respective personal
additives and seeing this would be a
great combination as joint CEOs
but isn't it defensive though because in
the fund management world funds are now
moving rapidly away from active fund
management of the type that you do
towards passive fund management cheap
index trackers a Britain way in the same
business everything is to fit the suit
you're always trying to defend your
position and and move forward and
standard life isn't has an incredibly
powerful business whenever I go out and
about in the UK I'm always amazed by the
number of people I'd bump into who we
help with their pensions and savings
so our inflows have been very robust
over the last year it's always been part
of our strategy our journey is to turn
the company upside down when I started
as Standard Life back in 2003 we were
Europe's largest Mutual Life Assurance
Company
remember the D mutual eyes
all the adventures of that well we got
through that and then we said what we
had to do was make this a global
investment company so increasingly
investments have being at the top and
the insurance has been the distribution
arm for the investment company but you
know we still have one and a quarter
million shareholders the numbers hardly
gone down the tall in the last ten years
and that says something about the
quality of the company loyalty so our
customers are quite a lot I mean indeed
Standard Life is a much bigger business
than Aberdeen and yet you're casting
this is a merger I mean some would say
this it's really a battle takeover of
Aberdeen but without you having to pay a
premium for takeover what look these are
people businesses and you have to
respect each other there's fine people
in Aberdeen I'm a please there's going
to be some fine members of the Aberdeen
board joining the standard life board
and but I think you have to be grown-up
if you want to make these combinations
you can't let ego you know sometimes
with chief executives or with boards
there's so much ego around you don't do
what's best for shareholders or for
governance and I think in this case
we've reached a solution which has you
seen from the share prices today is
really good for both sets of
shareholders but can having a cow chief
executives really work I mean having two
chief executives has been a recipe for
disaster everywhere else it's being
tried I think it's a disaster too unless
you think you through very carefully
Keith and Keaton might have known each
other for many years I've known both of
them for many years and I don't want to
psychoanalyze them on the programme but
actually they are different individuals
different strengths different qualities
so I'm really hopeful it'll work well
we've been working together well the
city Scuttlebutt's has it that in a year
or so time you'll take over the
chairmanship of Barclays and martin
gilbert the current aberdeen CEO could
then replace you as chairman is that
likely to happen well I mean who knows
what's going to happen but I've
guaranteed what I've given my word to
both my president bulbed and my new
board that I will see through this
integration and I will see through I'm
not the kind of person who likes to
leave a job half-finished as you know it
indeed but I mean if martin gilbert were
to become chairman at some future
gendered
event I mean the corporate governance
people a standard life would have a fit
if that happened in any other company
wouldn't they well we are very strong in
corporate governance which is why I
don't anybody should count their
chickens on this we are a very strong
corporate governance and what I'm so
he's a birdie but one of the strengths
of our firm is we we behave properly and
it's amazing how a simple thing like
behaving properly takes you a long way
in financial services 3 forward on job
cuts not them coming down the line
there'll be some there's 200 million of
efficiencies but a lot of that comes
from things like overlapping overseas
sales offices computer platforms etc etc
the headquarters of this company will be
in Scotland the other great news for
this in terms of Scotland this would be
a powerful global business headquartered
in Scotland